more games coming to playstation plus
splatoon 3 direct news and go hands-on
with square enix's latest to jrpg the
dire field chronicles early all this on
today's gamespot news coming to you
from inside spider-man
2018 sony has revealed the next batch of
free games for playstation plus extra
and premium subscribers the august 2022
ps plus game catalog lineup includes not
one but three yakuza games a recent
remake in the mana series the latest
ghost recon and more coming to the
service on august 16th to start you can
live your japanese crime family
fantasies with yakuza 0 yakuza kawami
and yakuza kuami 2. these mark the start
of yakuza offerings on ps plus with
others set to come later this year extra
and premium members can also get the 1v4
multiplayer game dead by daylight as
well as tom clancy's ghost recon
wildlands and the extremely wacky
adventure game bug snacks rounding out
the new additions will be metro exodus
trials of mana uno monopoly madness and
monopoly plus these are the premium
extras for the higher tiers separate
from the playstation plus essentials
games lineup extra and premium members
can grab those games too which this
month include tony hawk pro skater
oneplus 2 yakuza like a dragon and
little nightmares if you are subscribed
to playstation plus extra or premium
make sure to check out our list of the
best playstation games in that library
to download and play here on gamespot's
youtube splatoon 3 had its direct
spotlight revealing a ton of new info
about the game familia and newbie npcs
including splatoon 3's new hosts fry
shiver and big man the stingray
can't wait for the internet to just be
awash with erotic big man fan art a new
mode was shown off anarchy battles a new
ranked mode which rotates through a
number of match types as well as a slew
of new and returning maps of course one
of the most important aspects of a
splatoon game is its weapons and the
direct did not disappoint in addition to
a ton of returning weapons are the
splitanas a windshield wiper-esque
device as well as a bow and arrow-like
weapon the stringers weapons are also
getting upgrades in splatoon 3 with
special attachments there's the tactic
cooler a mini-fridge attachment that
provides refreshments that can buff your
teammates and the wave breaker that
creates waves that ripple out from your
character and can break your opponents
not quite as imaginative and name that
one while you wait to jump into a match
splatoon 3 ditches the series usual
waiting screen with an actual lobby that
has a practice range to test all the new
weapons an in-universe card game is also
coming to the title called table turf
battle and is a 1v1 tabletop version of
turf war with over 150 collectible cards
you can accumulate via playing the game
there were a ton of other details that
came out of the direct including a
splatoon 3 splatfest coming later in
august that will give you a taste of the
new game before its release so make sure
to check out the link in the description
for the full rundown while you wait to
play splatoon 3 on switch why don't you
check out the diofield chronicles demo
ahead of the game's official launch on
september 22nd players will be able to
try out the strategy rpg and after
experiencing the demo all progress made
will also be carried over to the full
game players will be able to experience
the entirety of chapter one which
includes real-time tactical battles and
strategy-based combat that utilizes
small squads each consisting of various
unit types with unique battlefield roles
the demo also introduces the player to
the blue fox mercenaries who will play a
major part in the story and the military
campaign
alright everyone that is it for today's
gamespot news are you jumping into the
yakuza series thanks to playstation plus
are you going to check out that splatoon
3 splatfest happening later in august
let us know in the comments below and
we'll see you here tomorrow on this roof
on gamespot